what the fuck did I just watch I am
quickly took Soper from this okay you
you've seen the show
it's did I get through the first episode
was that the first episode no what the
fuck did I just watch I have no idea
what was just put in front of me I
always wants to say that I hit - okay oh
I just don't have a reaction I maybe I
just watch I don't know how to put it
it's got there's like 90 more of these
something like that or 60 I don't know
I'm sorry I literally just watched this
and it's like since the camera went on
I'm trying to think of stuff what to say
setting up the camera about to talk
about I what the hell do you say to this
I there there is no intro whatsoever
even the intro isn't really an intro
it's like Adventure Time and it shows
all this weird stuff and it's like here
we go it's it's in some sort of magical
kingdom that looks like Candyland okay
there's no introductions to the
characters they're just sort of doing
stuff the the kid the boy I guess has I
don't know what that is I I thought it'd
be explained the thing out his head but
no it's just there's a princess
bubblegum who apparently is a scientist
also who likes bringing dead candy back
from the
said with science and it goes awry
because they're like candy zombies and
she gets all the candy people of the
kingdom to come into the castle to stall
them so that they're not scared by the
candy zombies because when candy people
get scared they blow up so the boy has
to distract the candy people because he
made a royal promise that he would not
tell the candy people or else they will
blow up and this dog who can I guess get
big or small or stretch into whatever he
wants cuz he did it a second ago I don't
know if that's a thing but he did it and
he wants to know what's going on and the
boy tries to distract the candy people
but the candy zombies break in and he
has them fight off the candy zombies by
blindfolding them all and saying that
they're pinatas but he gets the idea
from a pinata so aren't they kind of
like beating people it's like if you got
you know advice the idea from a little
kid and it's like oh I have a great idea
I'll have them beat little kids because
the pinata is not just a pinata it's a
living thing but they still go and
destroy them that confused me but it's
ok because he tells the dog who's in a
closet with sort of a unicorn Chinese
dragon because they're playing seven
minutes in heaven I'm assuming some kind
of kissing game but he comes out with
the jelly donut I didn't get that um
they come out see that all the candy
zombies are dead
and he tells him what happened breaking
the royal promise which means that these
giant gumball machine ice-cream cone
gods come out and grab them and say
you've broken the Royal promise so you
have to solve no before the solving it's
trial by fire which is literally they
give him a trial while breathing fire on
him he says that stupid so they decide
to do a math question instead which is
2+2 and he solves it and it just
coincidentally happens that that was the
last number needed for Bubblegum's old
scientific equation that can bring candy
people back to life and have them be
happy so they do that and then he says
breaking promises is great because it
means you can bring the dead back to
life I suppose that's the moral and then
he picks up this candy donut and start
squeezing them he's like don't do that
I'll fart and he farts that was episode
1 I'm not like a prequel you know like
it was meant to be bad like the Star
Wars movies no it was just that was our
introduction to this show and our
characters and our story in our land and
I don't know what to say was this not I
what would you say it's it's certainly
bizarre it's certainly strange it's
unpredictable because it doesn't really
give you anything to predict the start
off is not predictable nothing about it
is predictable it's just pure surreal
stoner humor the only way I can see the
story being put together like hey this
will make sense is if a guy got totally
stoned off his ass and was asked by his
son to read him a fairy tale but the
stoner can't read so he has to fake it
and this is the story he tells this is
just episode 1 how am I gonna get
through this I I'm still trying to put
it together outside it's very rare that
I don't have words to say but I do not
because that is one of the most bizarre
things I've ever seen because there is
no intro because there is no
establishing anything it's it just
starts I literally went into the DVD and
I started looking through that that
could have been episode 1 that could
have been halfway Thrones like this
campy episode 1 or maybe it's a
flashback I forgot to tell us what's
going at it no it just
is it just is adventure time and
bizarrely enough I do see the attraction
because it is so unapologetic for it and
clearly doesn't care if you get it or
not or if you're on board for it or if
you miss something it clearly doesn't
care it's just here's some shit and we
think it's funny or at least we did when
we were smoking whatever we were smoking
and maybe we can bring you into our very
bizarre high without having resort to
any kind of drugs so maybe this is like
some sort of great anti-drug message
that rather than go and do marijuana or
ass or whatever
hallucination inducing thing you want to
do just watch adventure time that's all
you need don't do drugs do adventure
time it'll give you the exact same thing
that you are looking for confusion but
happiness bright colors more confusion
the inability to put together what
you're seeing right in front of you
but still feeling good and laughing at
stuff that doesn't make sense I enjoyed
it
it's fun I don't know how I'm gonna do a
whole series on this I you might just
watch depending on where the show goes
if it can go anywhere from there really
you might just be watching the mental
breakdown of a man who may not have
clearly all been there before but I'm a
little less there now so episode 1